[Music]
shadow of war is an epic third-person
open-world action RPG and the sequel to
the award-winning shadow of Mordor this
walkthrough takes place many hours into
the game where we will show you one
example of the epic personal stories
created to the next generation of the
revolutionary Nemesis system
save middle-earth we will be journeying
deep behind enemy lines and using the
new Ring of Power ocean army and conquer
Mordor from within on the world map we
see the many regions he can conquer
every one of these regions is a distinct
environment with unique enemies and
allies including overlords war chief
captains followers fortresses
strongholds missions and men today we're
going to attack and conquer the mountain
valley of sarah go and take it from
Saran's overlord board Hakan the dragon
lord let's launch the assault
it's not only our enemies and the world
that makes an amateur system unique it
also are following Rob Duke the iron map
have armored cavalry that can charge
through the flames of artillery fire the
demolisher is a living battering ram
with the power to smash enemy defenses
with our followers at our side we must
first face the storm bringer for you and
you just me to die I was reborn with
he has a history and personal grudge
against us he used to be part of our
army before he betrayed her and joined
the Dark Lord he also carries a dark
curse which prevents us from using the
power of the new rage
charge into the flames of your reckoning
the Overlord has deployed multiple sport
defenses including speech peace and
flame Archer
Oh
our first objective will be to break
through the main gate
good boy knocker
that you feel it jouji me use the power
of the dark
with the stormbringer defeated we've
broken the curse and can unleash our
power at the demolisher breach of the
gate allowing our army to storm the fort
[Music]
there are many ways to conquer a force
from open combat self an infiltration
Oh
we've infiltrated a spy within the enemy
ranks Jedi has placed explosives
allowing us to sabotage the wall and
outflank the defender
did you really think you could kill me
five is also able to help clear the way
like slicing enemy in shadow of Mordor
the Nemesis system created memorable
stories of bloodshed and revenge in
shadow of war your followers can create
entirely new stories of loyalty betrayal
rivalry and even friendship thanks dad
are so short we've expanded the RPG
systems and shadow of war enormously
defeating storm bringer allows us to
collect this epic armor of Rohan and
equip it
range that I am defending
good job bring up
why
Wow
mounting Armored Cavalry allows us to
ride through these flames unharmed
[Music]
releasing and dominating the Drake let
us turn the overlords defenses against
[Music]
[Music]
you've terrified the flame of war now
Bend him to your will over the ring of
power allows us to dominate the minds of
our enemies I am you're telling them to
join our growing army now with the power
of the new ring and the help of our
followers we've defeated the war chief
we can face our ultimate nemesis in the
sport the Dragon Lord Himself time to
take what is a power with the Nemesis
system every overlord faced by every
player will be unique to their world and
the throne room itself has been
customized by the overlord as his
personal combat arena it's the Lord of
Mordor himself the brave you've made a
right leg aren't you why are you saying
my Drake's dead so much
[Music]
I know a thing or two about me and you
old sport
[Applause]
ha
let me show you how
it's my turn
[Music]
with the overload defeated thoughts are
aghast and this region of Moodle are
ours
conquering the region rewards us with
experience loot new followers and
resources it also creates a personal
base from which we train our forces
increase our power and upgrade our
defenses against Erin's counter-attacks
let's return to the army screen where we
can review our enemies and command our
followers we need to select one to
become the new overlord so we can spread
his influence throughout the region
creating an entirely original nemesis
fortress this war chief is a necromancer
he will shroud the fort in sorcery to
confuse and terrify tackers this war she
is a beast master he will allow us to
turn the creatures of Mordor against our
enemies but we're going to promote Raju
the war chief who charged through that
artillery assault and helped us bring
down orthicon the Dragon Lord as a
Marauder he can leap and pillage the
region for us
with our new overlord in place we can
upgrade the fortress increasing its
defenses and enlarging the size and
power of our armed
the landfill system means that every
element of this mission was dynamic and
unique no two flowers of the game will
experience the same story this is just
one step in our compost of model one
small example the millions of unique
stories players will create in Middle
Earth shadow of war
[Music]
all the bright Lord
[Music]
you
[Music]